[Music]
i have the great
privilege today of talking with ayan
jersey ali
she's one of my heroes i guess that's
the case ever since i read her book
infidel which i believe was published in
2006 she's also published nomad and
heretic and a new book which we're going
to talk about today
a daring book i would say which is in
keeping with her general
courage all things considered pray the
name of the book
immigration islam and the erosion of
women's rights
all topics that i don't believe you can
discuss without
bringing a tremendous amount of negative
attention to yourself um but
which in principle still need to be
discussed
you've had an amazing life ayan um i
don't know if it's the life anyone would
choose for themselves necessarily
maybe just for our viewers who aren't
familiar with us if you could
present a bit of biographical
information about yourself that would be
a good back
drop to the to the investigation into
your book that we're going to conduct
today and welcome to this
discussion i'm very pleased to see you
jordan thank you
very very much for having me and yes the
feeling is mutual you are also one of my
personal heroes and i thank you for your
courage
i was born in somalia and i grew up all
over the place my family
left somalia when i was about seven or
eight years old and then
we lived in saudi arabia in ethiopia i
was in kenya with my family for about
10 or 11 years and most of that time
my father was absent
and then he came back in 1992
and took what he called his
responsibility which was to find
me a husband and i didn't agree with
uh his choice of husband for me uh
this husband of mine then lived in
canada
and i was supposed to join him in canada
but instead of joining him in canada
i uh went along with
the family plan which was to go to a
relative in germany
and find my way from germany to canada
but instead of doing that
i went to the netherlands and i asked
for asylum and this was back in july
of 1992. how old were you then
i was 22 years old and
i took to a dutch society like a fish to
water
i learned the language i made friends
i went on to do a masters in political
science
and by 2000 2001
uh in my early 30s i had just done 30 i
was
leading the life of the average dutch
woman of my age
and and loving it i had just accepted
a job with a think tank a think tank
that works for the social democratic
party
and then 9 11 2001 happened
muslim terrorists 19 of them took
passenger airplanes and started to bring
down the twin towers
they wanted to bring down a white house
they had brought down a wing
of the pentagon and um you're old enough
to
remember that that was a significant
moment
uh in history for those of us uh who
were old enough to understand what was
going on
there were a lot of conversations people
were having in the netherlands and
abroad this has to do some of them
said with american foreign policy they
said it had to do
with injustice against the palestinian
people
they said that the 19 men were poor
and oppressed and victims of
you know economic uh challenges
and i said that it had nothing to do
with any of that
that the leader of the 19 men left us
enough information and we were able to
find
enough information to point that what
motivated them
was the conviction acting on the
conviction of the religious
beliefs they were waging jihad
and to pretend otherwise was wrong and i
didn't understand how sensational that
would be
and and i was given platforms by some of
the dutch newspapers radios and
television
and from being and complete unknown who
had just graduated
i became this depending on who you talk
to
either famous or infamous person
and i think the rest of the story is
public
and documented in infidel and
you you are you i know that at one point
in your life
you you had guards accompanying you
wherever you went is that still the case
that's still the case and jordan as you
know with security issues
um the main instruction i've had over
these years is
don't talk about that um but yes that's
still the case
and aside from a lot of
you know my family members acting
disappointed and even threatening me
losing some of my dutch friends because
they thought that i was
bending toward the right islamophobic
yeah i also had to live with
death threats and it's very interesting
when you look at
that you know if you if you go back in
that time when we were discussing
the threats to free speech and
i know a lot of people why in denial
probably
are still in denial about it but where
they would say there is
no um
there's really no distinction here to
see between
muslim civilization and christian
civilization western civilization other
civilizations all cultures are equal and
so on
it's just you know a handful of bad
people were giving everyone else a bad
name
but then over and over again we saw the
threats to
the freedom of conscience the freedom of
speech women's rights
the freedom of association the freedom
of the press and
never ever did i think that we would
have what we now
have which is not a threat
from outside forces whether they're
religious or not
but are threats from the inside from our
own universities
where a conversation like the one we're
having now or
the subject of this book is going to be
misinterpreted which is a charitable way
of saying
it's going to be dismissed yes well i i
must say
i'm quite terrified to have this
conversation
um and i i was also going to ask you
immediately what possibly possessed you
to write this book
i mean it's as if in some sense you're
looking at a sequence of hornet's nests
and decided to take a swing at the
largest one i mean i think there's every
reason to believe that
at least in the possibility that when i
air this
episode my channel will be demonetized
and that it could conceivably be taken
off the air altogether
and i've had my fair share not to the
same degree you have
certainly but i've had my fair share of
public attack and
and you know i'm rather embarrassed to
admit that i don't have the same
stomach for it that i once did um
so but anyways onward and upward
hypothetically
um so back to this i guess we'll start
to talk about this book
pray immigration islam and the erosion
of women's rights
i had an uneasy feeling reading it
continually i mean you do say right off
the bat
this is a trigger warning for the entire
book reading it you should be triggered
well i would say i was triggered by
reading it i was triggered partly
as a social scientist i would say to
begin with because
i as i went through the initial part of
the book in particular
which deals with statistics pertaining
to the sexual assault of women
i i was reminded of the many studies
that i've been involved in dealing with
complex multifactorial problems
and it's very very difficult
to deal scientifically or mathematically
or statistically
with a complex social issue and
you run into that problem or encounter
that problem over and over among many
other problems
when you're formulating your argument to
begin with for example
here and stop me if i get any of this
wrong
you're you're making a case that
there is some threat to women's rights
in
europe particularly and that that's
associated with immigration
and that some of that threat takes the
form of
enhanced susceptibility increased
susceptibility to sexual assault
and then you start to delve into the
sexual assault statistics
and then you run into the immediate
problems
for and it's perhaps worthwhile to walk
people through what some of these
problems are
how do you define sexual assault for
example
now you could define it as the
if you define it by the most severe
crimes let's say
rape then you miss all the data
that might be obtained when you consider
all the other forms of sexual
misbehavior
that might be regarded as assault
unwanted touching on a street for
example but if you include those
then you risk minimizing
the magnitude of the extremely serious
forms of a sexual assault like rape
and cri especially if you do it over a
lifetime and crank up the prevalence
rate so high that they start to become
meaningless now
i know it's an appalling thing that a
very large percentage of women and
perhaps an unknowable percentage
face unwanted physical unwanted sexual
attention psychological and physical
um but if if the definition of that
becomes so lacks that it's a hundred
percent of women
that suffer from it then you divert
attention away from
for example from the more serious forms
of sexual assault so
it's and then you outline as well the
difficulties of doing cross-cultural
comparison cross-country comparisons
because the definitions vary so much
from state to state
and the difficulty of tracking change in
sexual assault prevalence in any given
country because of the changing
definitions of sexual assault that occur
within states
and so i was tempted to throw up my
hands at
one point and think well it's impossible
to get to the bottom of this so
in the face of all that complexity what
argument have you laid out
and why do you think it's justifiable
so the argument i'm laying out first of
all
isn't it's the story
of women and their safety in the public
space
so in this book i'm not making i'm not
laying out an
argument about sexual violence committed
by
intimate partners if you wanted that
it would probably be easier to get those
statistics
it would be harder to find them
categorized along ethnic lines
but still possible and i'm not talking
about
sexual violence against women
in say in the office at work
the themes that were brought to light by
the me too movement so
those two things are not the subject of
this book what i'm talking about
is the public space and so i don't start
fast with statistics so i i you know i
really want
i'm not a social scientist and
i don't think of myself as a social
scientist in terms of
trying to acquire empirical data analyze
that and
interpret it what i do is it starts with
experience
it is in northern european countries
a decade and a half ago maybe even a
decade ago
women took it for granted that they were
safe
once they left their front door not all
women
some neighborhoods are worse than others
but in general
in 1992 when i came to holland i don't
recall
ever being um
assault feeling unsafe in the public in
the public space
i was with my dutch friends and asking i
thought it was
striking that women took it for granted
in the netherlands that they were safe
in the public
and i saw that in other northern
european countries and when i asked
questions about that
they said what is are you out of your
mind what's wrong with you
where you come from don't you take it
for granted and i described to them
the societies that i grew up in and
how incredibly difficult it was for a
woman to get out of her front
door and enter the public space
without being cats called after and so
then i go from
the descriptions of uh verbal
um sexual violence or sexual
uh propositions that are inappropriate
and lewd and obscene
and are harmful and hurtful all the way
to rape and these women were just
stunned a decade later i'm hearing
from white women in some of these
countries
describing situations that i thought
were but that's weird that's very
interesting that's a real
change and jordan
i know you know a little bit of my
background but i've also been engaged in
this debate about islam
integration immigration the unintended
consequences
of immigration and all the taboos around
that
so when i first proposed writing this
book
it was for instance my husband saying
the argument will no
it won't go anywhere because you will
not be able to get the statistics
and i thought what i'll try and so i
started calling up these
justice departments of these various
countries
and they would provide me with the
reports they had made
of sexual violence against women
in the public space and
some countries again are totally as you
describe
the definitions shift
some countries say we do
record sexual violence against women
but not the ethnicity of the
perpetrators or the religion of the
perpetrators
in some countries you would find the
testimonies of the victims and they
would say
that was an arab-looking man that was a
black man
that was a man who spoke with a foreign
accent and i would ask the people who
say that they've collected these
statistics
why don't you have that information
input
and then you would always run they would
it would always be off
the record but you would always run into
the issue
of well the issue of immigration is
really controversial the issue of islam
is
really controversial and if you take
those two and then you link it to sexual
violence
oh my god you're going to empower the
right-wing populist parties
you're going to stigmatize muslims and
islam it's not all muslim men it's a
universal phenomenon
and i agree with all of these things but
we still have a problem
the safety of women in general
in the public space is compromised
so how can we collect statistics if
as a social scientist you start
shrouding all these issues
with complex cultural and political
factors
please join let me give you an example
in from january of last year
to january of this year i think today is
what the last day was the first of
february
uh we have had all to live
with the pandemic we've had a lot of
conversations and disagreements about it
but in one year we've been able to
collect the most
important data statistical data that we
need
about what the virus is who's affected
who's likely to die who's likely to
survive what are the things that we need
to do
and we have in response to that data in
response to that knowledge that we
gather
put policy or policies in place
that constrain our liberties to a great
deal we've overcome
huge taboos the problem i'm talking
about this public safety and the safety
of women
i want to date it back at least for two
decades when it comes to women
in the general public space and we can
never even
agree on what data is important let
alone collect it effectively
and let alone produce effective policies
to address that
so i'm going to ask you rude questions
um because they're the sorts of
questions that
are going to be brought to bear in
relationship to this book
and so they popped into my mind
constantly um
in light of the fact that it's so
difficult to gather data
on something let's say
as definable as rape a
physical and we could narrow that down
even more unwanted
physical sexual penetration of a vagina
by a penis
how how do you go about ensuring that
your sense that
the safety of women which is a much
vaguer
construct say term concept that the
safety of women
in the public domain has been
compromised that's the first thing
because
if that isn't the case see because i
kept wondering well what exactly is the
problem
here and i did believe as a consequence
of reading your book that
your primary concern was that as the
public domain
if the public domain becomes less safe
then women are going to have to retreat
from from engagement in all on all sorts
of
public fronts and that there's nothing
about that that's good
that i believe is is the main thrust of
your argument and that
that and so then we'd have to ensure
that
not that women's safety is in fact being
compromised
that they feel that it's been
compromised and then the next part of
the argument is that
that can be associated with an increase
in immigration
specifically from islamic countries
and you even event some doubt about that
i believe because
at one point in your book you talk about
the problem
the cultural problem that might be
behind this being perhaps not so much
islam but polygamy itself and
its influence it's its influence on
islam
so i'm not disputing your claims i'm
trying to adopt
as i always do when i read anything well
anything i would say
the the most critical stance to find out
where where what's solid and so you're
obviously concerned about the safety of
women
and what what makes you think that your
concerns are warranted
so again i want to be and i don't think
it is rude at all
i think asking um these questions
is um is not only justified it's crucial
yes it's absolutely necessary for this
for this issue to ever be
to be dealt with one way or the other or
any other social issue that is of this
magnitude
i think the most important thing that i
can do any
any other observer can do is to say i
want this to be
questioned and one of the things about
the hard sciences for instance is that
you could replicate
data and then you could experiment you
can then
falsify or verify as you know with these
types of very complex social issues that
is
very very difficult having said that
if you were to go out and take the exact
same steps that i have done
i challenge you i will say i bet you you
will reach the same conclusions
now you it is very important to make the
distinction between something as
gruesome and as horrific as rape
and there is rape by one individual
against another individual but sometimes
it's done in groups
that's even more horrific
and it's not nearly as horrific as
somebody calling you
bad names as you you know walk by
or touching you or so
in terms of what is most gruesome
it is rape especially by groups and then
very often that leads to homicide
so some of the victims actually die and
i i didn't want
this book to be about just about that
when something like that happens in a
european country
that is recorded and in fact um
the the authorities make an attempt
at finding the perpetrators and bring
them bringing them to justice now you
can debate
if the severity of the punishment fits
the crime in in some of these countries
these conversations are going on
but no one is debating that that is
horrific
and that that should be and that's you
know you could only look at those
statistics
if you did that and then you ask those
same authorities
for the origins of the perpetrators
in many countries you are going to run
into we don't
recall we just don't record that kind of
data
and they have reasons for that germany
for instance because
of the history of the second world war
in the holocaust and what they had done
right all sorts of minorities uh and
other countries like
even the netherlands i i don't think
they would record the religious
aspect of it some of them will though
record i've seen this in norway i've
seen this in denmark i've seen it in
austria
even in germany at a given moment
there was a recording of the testimony
of the victim
or witnesses or some of the reporters
would say
today in court case xyz was tried
and the perpetrator was from iraq or
afghanistan
or syria or somalia or whatever and as
things evolved
journalists who are told not to do that
and victims would sometimes testify
those who survive
the audio and if this goes to justice
they would describe the physical
characteristics
of the perpetrators now that is the most
gruesome aspect of it
now go to the lightest let's just say
the verbal abuse
the touching the groping stuff
that in some countries is criminalized
recently in some countries it's not yet
criminalized but stuff that is seen
as inappropriate towards women things
that make women feel
unsafe and again the victims of that
kind of behavior will describe
who the assailants are
and they sometimes they'll those
recordings at
first some of these countries would put
down that information
these data points and see them as
important
but then income the political
correctness the identity politics
immigration is sensitive islam is
sensitive we don't want to stigmatize
and then you will see these data points
have been dropped
you will see statistics that make it
very clear that there is a correlation
at least
between a rise in sexual violence
against women
and immigration and then someone else
will be commissioned and will be told
okay
can you please give that a second look
and they would come and they would say
you know what sexual violence against
women is universal
yes well that's part of the complexity
of the problem because i was thinking as
well
well you also point out for example that
um many cases of sexual assault are
never
they're never brought to the police and
no one knows how many cases are like
that
and that's even more likely to be the
case for the more minor
forms if we're allowed to make a
hierarchy of sexual crimes which i think
is absolutely necessary
um it's even more true for the more
minor forms of
sexual harassment which i would say
would certainly be
certainly be um of sufficient
unpleasantness to potentially restrict
women's at least their sense of freedom
um in
in the public domain um but
so uh a critic and you've covered this
in the book as well a critic might
object well
this is going to happen in
under any immigration scenario if the
majority of the immigrants are male
because obviously males are implicated
in this sort of crime
and if they're young because young males
are more likely to be criminal
in all regards yeah and um
so maybe it's it has nothing to do with
country of origin
or ethnicity or or religious background
right but it's purely a demographic
matter
and then there's another issue which is
even if it is
true that that immigration policy
tilts so that young males are more
likely to immigrate
um that doesn't necessarily mean that
that should be stopped
there's a price to be paid for it but
there's potential benefits from it as
well
and so the
layout for for everyone yeah as
exactly what you think the problem is
and and why
see because the other thing i thought
too was well why did ian's critics are
going to say
there's lots of contributors to violence
against women that could conceivably be
talked about and you might say well you
should
attend to those that are the most
dramatic
uh the most consequential the most
severe but perhaps also to those that
might be the most easily addressed so
for example
i always think when i look at stats
about violence against women that we
should have a conversation a protracted
conversation about alcohol
because if you alcohol contributes
victims and perpetrators of violent
crimes about 50 percent of them are
alcohol intoxicated it's a massive
contributor to
to violence of all types domestic
violence every type of violence
and so if
the kind of violence that you're
describing is in fact related to
immigration
which is a difficult thing to prove
how high up in the hierarchy of things
to be concerned about that should that
be
especially given the benefits of
the humanitarian benefits even of an of
a relatively more open immigration
policy
so here i think again we're going to
start talking about the trade-offs
and i think in terms of these trade-offs
what we're seeing is
that the um
in the way i see it is that the rights
of women
are being and their freedoms and their
safety has been compromised
um when say you know
is immigration beneficial is and then
like the way you say it's even uh on
humanitarian
grounds just being compassionate to
fellow human beings
right from syria parts to different
parts of africa different parts of
south asia these men are suffering
we should feel compassion for them i
think it should be possible to
feel compassion for them and accommodate
them in
as much in every way we can without
selling out
women now in terms of the contention
that that particular demographic when
you have
a young men of a certain age in large
groups
they tend to engage in violence
including sexual violence that is true i
don't dispute it i describe it in the
book
anywhere where you have any kind of
conflict the civil wars the wars that
europe overcame even gang violence here
in
the united states of america uh look at
places like guatemala el salvador
all of those places where that you have
a cohort of young
men with no jobs with no purpose in life
and in a machismo type of society
and there is violence this disorder and
then including
sexual violence so that's not something
i'm disputing
or something that i want to exaggerate
in terms of the alcohol component
i think we have had and probably will
continue
to have that conversation about say
um the context i'm thinking of
is in college most colleges where
young men will drink and young women
will drink and then they will go off
into their dorms
both of them drunk and up to a point
the young man involved will argue i
thought all this time
that it was voluntary and the next
morning the young woman will wake up and
say
it wasn't and that is i think a
conversation we will continue to have
and you're absolutely right
if you consume that amount of alcohol
and you put yourself in a vulnerable
place
i think you should hold yourself
as an individual and i'm talking about
as the female as well
that you have agency you have
responsibilities
and we should we should raise our girls
if they don't want to have sex and don't
go to the dorm then don't go to the room
at 10 p.m
and don't drink as much as you know so
enough to overwhelm you so that's a
debate that we are going
we will continue to have but that's not
the subject of this book
but before please before we go to the
next one the cases i
describe let's just say okay the
statistics
my critics let's say my critics might
look into these statistics and say
there's nothing to see here
all right then you go to the description
that i get from the women and i'm not
talking about a context
of women who are behaving in ways that
might be confusing that's not what i'm
talking about i'm talking about a woman
a mother in a park who's pushing her
toddler
pushing her baby with her toddler
walking next to her or a woman jogging
or a woman going to do her grocery
shopping or a woman coming home from
work and taking the train and
who is terrified by a group of young men
who think it's a game
i'm talking about different things where
you would say
i'd say i'll give you another data point
there are now neighborhoods
where european women have decided
no one is going to protect me so i just
want to go there
there are two documentary makers that
i've spoken to who have
you know because the phenomenon has been
going on for some time
have decided they were going to make a
documentary about this visit
these women-free zones and actually
confront
the men the proprietors of these places
and say
there's that one example where they
order i think coffee and they asked to
leave
and they have a conversation about but
why should i leave
these are these are female filmmakers
who are doing this
these are female filmmakers who are con
who have seen in france
certain neighborhoods have become
inaccessible for women
they want to address that they go and
talk to the proprietors of these cafes
and things
and who is it that brings up the
cultural element
it's not the women it's not the research
or the statistician
it's the men themselves who say no
you're not safe here it's inappropriate
and she says
but this is his uh this is not like some
place in algeria
and he says this part is you better go
we have another example in sweden uh
northern europe where a politician is
taken to a neighborhood and he's asked
what is missing
and he's baffled and he couldn't imagine
what was missing
and you looked around it was women so
there are ways of looking at the
complexity of
this issue and not only
relying on the statistics that are
gathered by the institutions
that are actually supposed to be
enforcing
the values the rule of law the
protection of women
because they gather the data and like
you when you said i finish the book and
then i throw my hands up in the air what
are we going to do about it many of them
do exactly that they throw their hands
up in the air and they decide
let it be yeah well i it's very
difficult for me to understand
in in the present political state of the
west it's very difficult for me to
understand how a conversation about this
can really be undertaken because
i i don't think we're capable of doing
it i mean
um which is partly why it's so stressful
to undertake
uh to try to undertake a conversation
like this
i guess what we're trying to do the
problem is is that we're pitting
two virtues against each other and those
are
the most difficult moral conundrums
it's not wrong versus right it's right
versus right
um yes and on the one hand there's
compassion for the dispossessed
including dispossessed young men
in war-torn countries um war-torn
and catastrophically catastrophically
riven countries and the
benefits of immigration economically and
on humanitarian basis and then there on
the other hand
there's the the safety of women
and it's very difficult not to be for
both of those
but unfortunately there are
circumstances where
the interests are not going to align
in a context like this one and the
context is where
we have been having conversations not
just about
having compassion for dispossessed
men and not allowing them to then
violate the rights of women
we've been having similar conversations
about the limits of free speech
and what you sometimes see is people
concluding well
let's not have that win-win where we
protect free speech
but we also protect against incitement
and violence that would be a rational
discussion to have
it would be a rational outcome it would
be a good outcome for our society
we have this other confrontation say
between transgender rights
and then compromising the rights of
women we could have a win when we can
lift up transgender people
and respect their freedoms and their
dignity and
for them to live the way they want to
live without compromising the rights of
women
but that is the context we live in and
that's when you open this conversation
you said you were terrified of being
deplatformed if we were to have this
conversation and i think it's
very very important in a free and
liberal society
that adheres to the rule of law to have
these uncomfortable conversations
i don't care so let's walk through the
central argument again is that you
you you're attempting to demonstrate in
the book that
using statistics and you outline the
unreliability of the
statistics um and the difficulty of
obtaining them but
all using statistics and also like
on-the-ground anthropology and case
reports essentially to make the case
that there has been
a deterioration in the the public safety
of women over the last you'd say 10
years perhaps um
i think in the last 10 years it's been
more more pronounced
but i think it's been it's been going on
for at least
20 years depending on where you are so
certain neighborhoods in paris or
messiah
or malmo you could you could say or in
certain you know the tower hamlets area
in uh
in the uk right around london
some of those places you could go as far
back as 20 years
even longer and and that that
that again that that deterioration is
linked to
to it to to poor immigration policy or
or to
or or to or to what's
what exactly is the problem is the
problem the immigration policy is that
because i might also say i i mentioned
youth and masculinity as contributing
factors to
to violent behavior yeah um but
unemployment as well is going to be a
contributing factor
i know that's all true so all the
socio-economic
factors these are all contributing
factors
and people actually are i would say
more willing to talk they feel like
they're more licensed to talk about the
socio-economic factors
than they are licensed to talk about the
cultural factors
so if you have men and families
men and women come from countries where
men and women
relate to one another differently in the
public space and in the private space
and then they come to liberal societies
and the values are different
then yes all the very complex
socio-economic aspects are there but the
question is are those the defining ones
or is it the cultural aspects and then
my conclusion is
it is for integration policies in other
words for assimilation policies
and it is not it's very difficult
to culturally assimilate minorities
if the receiving societies are not
confident
in their own values and so the the
the the process of assimilation
and developing successful assimilation
that is socializing these
young men into the valiant women into
the values of the host society
this is all compromised by that moral
relativist attitude where we were saying
you can you can integrate and we will
only talk about the social economic
aspects
when it comes to the values you can keep
we're not going to question those
and so there was not at any time
there was a proposition to yes impose
the values of liberal societies on
the incoming minorities there would be
an opposition to that this still is an
opposition to that
from within saying to do that
is to recolonize them it's ethnocentric
it's
eurocentric it is uh it's arrogant
um it's racist it is xenophobic it's an
excuse to keep people
out and so the integration process has
been frustrated
on the one hand from the establishment
that is relativist on the other hand
by the populist and extreme right-wing
parties that are saying we don't want
anybody assimilating we don't want them
deport them
and then you have this other third force
which is the islamists the radical
muslims
who are preaching in the mosques to
muslim minorities
and telling them do not adopt the values
of the infidels of the host societies
because they're unislamic and so if you
say
if you ask me the greatest failure is
it's the failure
of the simulation process of the
integration process
okay and so let's decompose that if we
had a more effective assimilation policy
what do you think that should look like
i mean the obvious issue is employment
and perhaps
perhaps the problem would disappear to a
large degree
if if immigration policy
was matched to employment policy i'm
obviously not sure how that could be
done it's a very complicated problem
but perhaps one policy shouldn't be
developed in the absence of another
but i'm i'm wondering so people read
your book and let's say they
accept your conclusions that and can
i'm going to get you to state again
we've sort of developed the first part
of
your statement but which is that women
are being compromised with regards to
their safety in public spaces and
that's starting to impose
counterproductive restrictions on their
activities
and the second part is and that's
importantly a consequence of poorly
designed immigration policies that allow
for the
um arrival of people from cultures where
women's rights are not
valued i'm i'm i'm not doing a
disservice to your book to make that
summary i i'm hoping no you're not
so it's i think it it
is totally possible to make the case
that you can get people to come from
um societies that are very different in
in their cultural outlook and in their
social socioeconomic
outlook but if then the receiving
society acknowledges that there is a
problem
and develops an appropriate integration
or assimilation regime
then you could continue to have that
flow of people coming in so yes
first of all the immigration policies
are themselves poorly designed
there's a lot of talk of asylum and
refugees and humanitarianism
and compassion and very little about
the consequences on the ground for the
receiving societies
as this scale as the number goes up and
up well you use
germany as an instructive example and
maybe we can just walk through that a
bit
because you're you yes you stated quite
bluntly in your book that angela merkel
was motivated to switch her attitude
towards
refugees and the borders of germany as a
consequence of an emotional response
a compassionate response and that
well thought through policies weren't in
place to
to back up her transformative actions
and i spoke to german citizens who lived
with her
livid they voted for her or they voted
for
the sdp the social democratic party in
germany
so they are not these are not right-wing
extremists
who want uh to close the doors to
immigrants
but these are people who are livid livid
very angry and saying this was
uh spontaneous it wasn't
thought through uh and they pointed to
all the
integration issues that were already
straining let me say relations between
various ethnic groups
and they said we hadn't even attended to
that we hadn't
these are people who were in the second
generation and we were having
assimilation issues with those
and now you open the gates and you say
okay everybody come in because
i feel for sorry for this uh little girl
uh
who um who you know who's really upset
and the cameras are on me so people were
really angry with her but again i still
don't think
that that answers the question the
deeper question
which uh most europeans maybe
right now most uh people on the
left side of this issue don't want to
face
which is it's not the socio-economics
that changes the culture it is the
culture
that changes the social economics do you
do you know much about the immigration
situation in canada
a little bit yes and i know that canada
in some ways
looks more like europe than north
america
well because they took in large numbers
of immigrant men and some of these
situations that i described some of
these anecdotes i think i could see a
lot of them happening
in in canada yeah well it's not been
obvious to me that in cities like
montreal and toronto
that we've seen a palpable increase in
the kind of street activity that has
produced a
decrement in women's feeling of safety i
haven't
that that's not something i've been
personally aware of i
i don't know if that means that canada
might be doing something right
it isn't obvious to me that our cities
montreal and toronto in particular which
have the biggest immigrant communities
especially toronto
hasn't fallen prey to segregation
and the the development of communities
that are
distinctively separate from the other
communities in the city
i mean they're obviously ethnic enclaves
in toronto but
i've never had the sense that we have
the same problem here for example as
as has manifested itself in france you
know and
canada does have an official policy of
multiculturalism and i don't think that
we're walking down the
um more intense assimilation route that
you were
describing i mean i'm obviously very
pleased to see that it's certainly not
been part of
that the kind of problems that you're
describing haven't really become
part of the canadian national
conversation i mean it's a strange time
now of course with everyone locked down
with covet but
it's possible i don't know why things
have
perhaps turned out better here but they
seem to have
that well there is this one um again i'm
not an
expert on canadian immigration and
integration policies but one thing that
i found striking about
canada is the selection at the gate
so canada has its own resettlement
policies it has a very aggressive i
would say compared to some other
countries
trying to get in skilled labor for
instance you have to speak english you
have to
you have to meet a lot of criteria
before
you can you can get into canada
but there's also geography i mean if you
look at
the way it it it's become
incredibly difficult for european
authorities
to keep out spontaneous immigration
so everybody wants to select their
immigrants
and some kind for some countries it's
easier than others
and i think in canada and australia are
some of the countries
um that have that geographical right
that's a very good one that's a good
point yes absolutely we we weren't
we're not as close to syria and so
that protected or that that
that distance dust from the
the downstream consequences of the
syrian conflict
and not just the syrian conflict uh the
economic travails of the continent of
africa you know
coming you can come through libya you
can come through people just
arrive in boats and the european
authorities that
uh you know that deploy the coast guards
are confronted with do you let's these
fellow human
beings die or do you rescue them and
bring them in and then when you bring
them in whose responsibility are they
and the conversation doesn't seem to go
beyond that
and i don't think you've seen something
like that in god
we've seen something like this in the
u.s from some of these failed or failing
latin american countries with the
caravans and building the wall and
so we we have those conversations in
america but i don't know
no i think that's a good i think that's
a good analysis the simplest explanation
could well be that canada's geographical
position has protected it against many
of the events or shielded us against
many of the events that have made
immigration such a contentious issue in
other countries
yeah because you can select you can
select beforehand
and also i think canada has uh canada
departs
uh canada requires as far as i know that
if you want to
wan if you want to go and work and live
there that you have someone
uh to sponsor you they have all of these
requirements
that they can actually enforce having
said that
you've had a number of honor killings in
canada you've had a number of terrorist
attacks in canada
you have a number of extreme right-wing
incidents
in attacks in canada so it's not like
you know you're protected from
from some of these manifestations
so you you suggested just a few minutes
ago that
this is an extremely contentious issue i
mean one of the things i was struck
when i read about when i read your book
infidel it was so interesting to see
how you responded to dutch culture
because i got to see
what one of the western countries looked
like
through the eyes of someone who was
decidedly non-western
i remember for example your amazement
when you saw that a dutch bus
that there was a sign indicating when a
dutch bus public transportation bus was
going to arrive and that it actually
arrived at that time
and and and i thought that was an
extremely
powerful part of the book because it is
a kind of miracle that that sort of
thing can occur it
it requires an incredible amount of
social organization and
holland is a great example of a country
that couldn't even exist without that
large-scale tightly knit almost
machine-like
organization given that a huge
proportion of their country would
actually be underwater if it failed
right and you you're making a you make a
case in infidel
you're making a case now that it in
order for the west to develop an
effective
integration policy that would enable an
effective immigration policy that we
have to have
faith in our own values the values that
gave rise say
to the idea of equal rights for women to
accept
that those the rise of that idea was
something
perhaps distinctively western
and that we need to teach those we
need to have enough faith in those
presumptions to teach them to newcomers
that strikes me that the probability
that we're going to
do that strikes me as extraordinarily
low
if that's what's necessary because i
don't think i mean
the last time i was in holland i was
struck by the degree to which
all the dutch people that i talked to
seemed to accept the proposition that
they didn't really have much of a
culture at all
that there was nothing particularly
special about dutch culture perhaps that
it even existed and
certainly didn't feel that it was of
sufficient quality to
impose on other people i think we
and and how would you address when
you're criticized for being
a neo-colonist let's say how do you
you're in such a strange position
because
of your your your your where you were
born and
how you immigrated and don't do you
think that there is
a danger in in the western assertion of
primacy of value for example and and is
is that such a danger that it mitigates
against
any attempts to assimilate immigrants
for example
i think the way you started with
you know the bus arriving on time and
for something like that to happen
um that a society that is hyper
organized
and you want to call that western i'm
happy to call it western
right you some people just call it
modernity
i don't know some people think it was
just lucky
i think there's a bit of everything
but if you then look at societies where
the bus
doesn't come on time that is one factor
and i just really like
the time factor in fact we can we we
should just have one podcast only about
that things happening on time
and in a predictable fashion for
millions of people how do you organize
that and i think
that sort of makes western society
distinct
from societies that haven't managed to
find a way of dealing with time
effectively and efficiently the second
thing is what we've been talking about
all this time
and it's violence that is suppressing
male violence
and channeling it so that it has other
outlets
instead of disrupting society and it
being used against women
the sec the third one i would say is
money
and it is for societies to
have these large surpluses where they
can actually
take care of the weak they can afford
compassion compassion is not just
something
you say i feel sorry for you we pay
taxes so that
we can pay for people's for the
dispossessed
and we can pay for their medical care we
can pay for the housing we can
so and that again greatly enhances
stability and social stability and then
finally it's
sex which is not something that you can
spontaneously have whenever whatever you
know
again it's not perfect but compared to
some other societies
unwanted diseases unwanted babies rapes
and sexual violence
all of that in western societies seem to
be really
different now you take those four
factors
and you say we're going to bring people
in
from or people from societies want who
don't have that
should we um bring them into this
call it's first assimilation or just
socialization
or freeze whatever you want to call it
but if we fail to do that and the number
gets
ever bigger then we are going to have
unstable societies we're going to have
and the dutch can say and i've had the
swedes to do the same thing i've had
germans say the same thing to me french
there is nothing uniquely different from
my culture maybe because they take it
for granted because
it's never been challenged they all look
alike they think alike
and then one day well you do take
whatever's around you all the time for
granted and it's
clearly the case that we don't
understand our own cultures
let alone other people's cultures
you don't understand what you
you don't understand what you have until
you don't have it anymore
and what what did you what
have you experienced the west as having
the values that should be transmitted to
the immigrant population that we're
inviting in what's crucial in your
estimation
and how do you communicate it i mean you
tried to do that when you wrote infidel
right and i'm trying to do it again in
this book and i've tried to do it in
heretic i try to do in every book
in using different sentences but pretty
much saying the same thing which is
before i came to the netherlands i
i knew of the concept of freedom but to
me it was a dream
it wasn't something you had so when i
came to holland i was stunned of course
in a good way i i
felt safe as a woman in any kind of
space
that's not something i was used to i was
told that i had equal rights
before men so when my the man that my
husband was my father married me off to
when he came to claim me the woman at
the asylum seeker center told him you
don't have to go with him you can call
the police
and we called the police and i didn't go
with him
right i can remember how stunned you
were your account in infidel that the
police were actually there to help you
and that you could rely on them you can
rely on them and she explained and this
is
and then i said what what can i do in
retina she said you don't have to do
anything interchange
this is the law and that was the law
when it was enforced
and again that is something she was just
as shocked as i was because she's so
there are places where they do this sort
of thing
and it is oh my goodness so that i i can
give you a whole list of things that i
didn't
have and i even took it for granted that
i didn't have those things
and then come to free societies and then
you can read as many books as you want
you can befriend whoever you want
you can sleep with whomever you want you
can you won't find
you know you might be rejected from this
job or that job but it is
taken for granted that you can find your
own employment and if you do you can
keep the money that you make from that
i i've been saying the same same thing
over and over again you can associate
with whoever you want
again in our conversation when we
started i i
told you some of these things are
changing and they're not changing just
because of external factors like
islam or immigration they're changing
from within
because a lot of us
people who are born and raised here for
generations
have decided that they are disappointed
in modernity they call themselves
postmodernists or critical race
theorists so
whatever you name it but this is
ideology that's taking on
uh you can see it in newsrooms in you
know publication houses
tech world and there is
an alarming rejection of
the fruits of modernity of
free speech of all the things that
that i was impressed with when i came to
the west
so you contrast
an islamic attitude towards women with a
western attitude towards women
so do we say that that's a contrast
between
the islamic attitude towards women and
the judeo-christian attitude towards
women
is it reasonable to make that a
religious issue and
or what do you think about that i mean
is this
is it yeah it is a religious issue it's
a cultural issue
it's a it's also an issue of not only
generating and being the motto
behind modernity and constantly
modernizing which is what western
societies are constantly doing
and then obviously the religious
component for me when i analyze
the leadership of islam is the
disappointment
with modernity and the rejection of that
and again that is why
what are they rejecting do you think
that and that we've accepted what are
the differences that
it enables the emergence of the idea
that women could be equal or that they
are equal and that they should be
that that equality should be fostered
and treasured and developed
what's the difference and maybe
i mean i'm i'm not expecting you
necessarily to know the answer to that
but
but it is the issue well the issue is
when when you study the narrative
that the radical muslims preach
and and propagate
there is this deep disappointment
that islam is no longer the dominant
force of the globe
and the answer that they give to that
question is because they strayed away
from the pure doctrine and the behavior
of the prophet especially when he was in
medina
and he had become so powerful he had
conquered not only arabia but then went
beyond and then his disciples went
to almost every continent and they were
dominant
then what went wrong and i think people
like baton russell and others have tried
to give the answer
that and they came late to the game of
modernity and then
had these debates about well
if we want to move forward and catch up
with the west
when they looked down on then we have to
become like them
that was the attempt that kamal ataturk
made in turkey
but then another force a retrograde
force
this is these are our modern islamists
said no that is actually the wrong
answer
we have to make them submit to us
and when i say they reject modernity
they they like the gadgets and the
nuclear weapons
and that sort of modern stuff that
makes them feel dominant or strong
but when it comes to adopting
attitudes such as liberating women
they recoil from that absolutely they
recoil from that because they think
that's what's going to take them about
that's looking like them or running
your societies according to this that
time machine
that the west does they think that
that's all empty
looking at the clock all the time
so there are aspects about the west that
they admire and want to incorporate
but the end goal is that it is not
it is not um their goal
to adopt some of these western values
but a lot of people are voting with
their feet
there are people who are poor
dispossessed
subjected to all sorts of violence who
want to come to the west and start all
over again
and those are the people we are talking
about and i think the people to give
those people a chance to
actually become a part of modernity and
modern society is to assimilate them
and the way to do it is just by
admitting that some of these
the voting with the fee says it all
well you know the the classic response
to that
the classic criticism of that
perspective would be that
those dispossessed people wouldn't have
had to vote with their feet
if the west hadn't engaged in its
colonial mission and devastated the
economic
uh opportunities of of two-thirds of the
globe while elevating themselves to
positions of unearned superiority and of
course
there's no shortage of evidence for that
if that's the evidence that you
choose to look at and sorting that all
out seems to be impossibly difficult
um the west is guilty for
all the crimes that have been committed
in its name
and many of those crimes were real and
so
i don't we don't know how to uphold what
we have of value
while simultaneously atoning for our
past sins
maybe even the ways i i would say we
could at least
admit that our past sins were the
failure of our
the failure to live up to our values
rather than the values themselves
but it that's certainly not it's
certainly not the case that everyone's
going to agree
to that it's a real mystery why
the idea of equality between the genders
or equality between men and things
in general came about you know it to me
it seems to have
a deep rooting in the in the idea of the
universal soul
and the intrinsic value of each person
and the intrinsic value of each person's
capacity for speech and creative
production
i think that's a deeply judeo-christian
idea
its roots go deeper than that i don't
understand
i don't know if there is a an islamic
equivalent
i think first of all just by telling
only one side of the story the story
of um
what is making a lot of people in the
west feel guilty and that they feel that
they have to atone for
the colonization the slavery the
segregation
all of these well-documented terrible
things that
western societies have engaged in that
is one side of the story but there's
also another side of the story
and the other side of the story is that
it is westerners who took the initiative
among humanity to change all of that to
end slavery to end
segregation to aspire for equality so if
you're going to tell the story then it's
better to tell both sides of the story
now for the people who tell only the
negative side of the story who
are toppling statues and saying the only
way to redeem
westerners is for them to destroy
everything and start all over again
i think even with those aside from the
the obvious nihilism
the let's just destroy stuff and and and
the selective
telling of the story there's also an
element
of superiority in there an element of
sorry an element of
of superiority or supremacy because
only whites and westerners are held
for bad things they did in the past or
do today
do you mean about bad things that were
that happened all together or
specifically that bad things the bad
things that were perpetrated by
europeans
i mean it's certainly the case that
slavery was a human universal
it's not something unique to european
society by any stretch of the
imagination
and so was colonialism and so was
and is segregation still to this day
take a continent like india where the
caste system is still
vibrant and healthy or any take any
of the arab countries where people with
my skin color are still regarded as
slaves
so i think if you want to if you want
to uh litigate history and all the
things that were done
bad by human beings selecting
only whites and especially white men and
saying only
they have to forever atone for their
sins
is in itself an expression of supremacy
because
holding the arabs and holding
the chinese and the chinese right now
are engaged in a genocide against the
uyghur people
we have reports of them um forcibly
sterilizing women
why can't we hold them to the same moral
standard
that we are holding ourselves so you
think it's what do you think it's
inappropriately colonialist
for white europeans to attribute
universal human guilt to themselves
it's an expression of of supremacy
it's an expression of only we can meet
those high
very high standards not the rest of
humanity
they are all victims in one way or the
other
or we just take it for granted they just
can't do it you know the chinese
and the violations of human rights why
even address it they don't know how to
do it
so we only do you see where there's the
nihilism there's the selective telling
of the story
but like deep down when you when you
read this stuff over and over again it's
like actually what you're saying is you
can hold those standards to yourself but
not to me
well i've never heard that argument
before it's extremely interesting and
very like darkly comical
what conclusion would you like
your readers and anybody concerned with
public policy to come to as
a consequence of reading well let's say
your books
pray in particular since it's your last
book
yeah is it you you
you you think that there is a clash of
civilizations and that we should be
aware of that
it's manifestations here and there um i
don't want to put words in your mouth
yeah you're right so there is indeed a
clash at least even if you don't want to
call it a clash of civilizations
because people responded badly to that
you can call it
unmistakably a clash of values
and in that encounter
between the cultures and the value
systems the conclusion of this book
is we can
assimilate or integrate whatever the
europeans call it
these young men who are dispossessed and
who are vulnerable
without sacrificing the rights of women
but we can't do that unless we
forthrightly confront
the problems that are associated with an
open with a more open immigration policy
and that is the first step that is the
first step and even
maybe even a step ahead of that
is we have to have these conversations
so let's
um let's stop putting these issues
putting a taboo over these issues
we have to see the way these things are
linked if you want to do that
like stop using you and i started our
conversation with statistics and
stop using statistics as a tool
of obfuscation as a tool of lying about
things that are going on
let's use statistics and data actually
to
to open you know to solve these problems
and we can't
if we if we keep on declaring
uh if we demonize one another and we
moralize towards one another
and and then we don't know where to go
from there so then we start compromising
free speech and so then you can't have
these conversations so
maybe the first step is i wish this book
would only contribute
to the opening of that conversation it's
not just about women
it's really it's about this
how to coexist with one another in
places
in europe in america on the globe
all right i've had the distinct pleasure
complicated pleasure speaking with ayan
hershey ali today
and she's the author of multiple books
including this one their newest
published in 2021
called pray immigration islam and the
erosion of women's rights
ayan is launching a podcast
monday which is february
8th monday february 8th and as well as
launching her new website which is i
unhersely.com
i'd encourage anybody who wants to know
more about ian's thinking
to visit her website and to attend to
her podcast which i'm sure will be very
interesting
and no doubt
perhaps more interesting than than
people will be able to tolerate
we'll see um thank you very much for
talking with me today
uh ayan it was a pleasure to see you
again
thank you jordan thank you so very much
and we could have continued this
for a good long time but
had to go into the kids so thank you so
much for having me
bye bye bye
[Music]
you